as mentioned I'm Anna watt and up until
two weeks ago
for Stanford University building
accessible user centered websites and
web product so we supported the
university's over 3,000 websites
we're sort of operated as an in-house
Drupal webshop and I work directly with
our development team back in front end
of and visual and user experience
designers but I actually just started a
new position just last Wednesday at a
startup in Seattle called text EO as a
community manager but while I was at
Stanford I worked on campus for the
first six months and then I decided to
move to Seattle where I continued
working for them remotely for the last
two years and when I moved I was really
missing that sense of community so I
started a Stanford community of practice
for distributed and remote workers which
was a community that met entirely
virtually to discuss this culture shift
of the future of work and what that
looked like and specifically the
challenges facing technology teams in
higher education so first I want to
start off by saying I am NOT here to
push a remote first agenda I know that
there are some companies doing not
really successfully but really I want to
help support the culture shift around
what remote working really looks like
and how you can work with a distributed
team and working in tech you will
inevitably end up in a situation where
you're working with someone in a
different physical location as you even
if that means they're in a different
office or even a different conference
room on another floor and I encourage
you not to just cancel your remote
meetings because of that so or your
collaborative meetings that is so I have
to tell you this talk is already going
so much better than the very first talk
I ever gave at a conference I was
introducing this new community of
practice for remote workers at
Stanford's itn conference which brings
together 500 of Stanford's IT
professionals from all across the
university I flew back to Palo Alto
California on campus from Seattle and
I'm originally from the Bay Area as I
said I'll just stay with my parents in
Pacifica which is this cute little beach
town about 30 minutes away without
traffic on a good day so I gave myself
an hour and a half to get there and
believe it or not
it took me an hour and a half to get
there and I was late to my first ever
talk I got stuck in traffic when I
finally got to campus I parked the staff
parking lot about half a mile away from
the conference center I had to book it
across campus hoof it up a flight of
stairs three stairs at a time and I go
blasting through the conference doors to
see my speaking partner on stage
nervously laughing and introducing me so
I climb up on stage out of breath finish
the talk humiliated but it turns out
that everyone thought that we had staged
this that this was this big scripted
moment right because the irony was that
we were introducing this community of
practice because so many people were
dealing with their commute time
specifically at Stanford they had
doubled within the last year nailed that
one
so I go busting through the door they
recorded it I'd show you a video but I'm
not going to and the reality is that in
San Francisco Bay Area and I'm sure this
is true in many other cities San
Francisco workers have quit a job due to
a grueling drive to work that's one in
three San Francisco workers and this
came from the 2018 study by Robert Half
a talent firm yikes I'm sure some of you
can maybe even relate to this here and
it's not just traffic that's the problem
there's this affordable housing crisis
happening in many major tech hubs and I
grew up in the Bay Area my entire family
is still there but I personally made the
decision to move so I could afford a
home and I knew that that was a decision
was also a privilege that I had and I
know several other people that have made
that same decision to move away from
their family in order to afford a
different lifestyle and if you're having
a hard time thinking about how remote
working might impact you or your
employers I encourage you to check out
this talk by Erica D Fox called new in
town I saw this talk at the write speak
code conference in Portland Oregon of
August 2017 there's a link at the top
that we link but this talk confronts the
impact of the tech industry on
gentrification and I can't do this talk
justice so I just encourage you to watch
it after
you know when you go back after this
conference and it really talks about
that impact and specifically how remote
working can help offset some of those
issues along with other insightful
research and ideas so check that out
because the other thing is anytime you
talk about remote working the stigma is
this is what you're doing maybe I'll be
doing this in a few hours because we're
here but realistically this was not my
life this is not what it looked like to
work from home somehow you're on a beach
with Wi-Fi maybe there's a cocktail but
that certainly is not the reality for
most remote workers this is what my
office looks like I worked in my house
between four walls from 9:00 to 5:00
every day that is my desk and that is my
huge cat Lambert he's part Maine [ __ ] so
he's just big but if you zoom in you'll
see like I'm on slack having a
discussion about gdpr compliance not
looking up flights to Mexico with
infinity pools and Wi-Fi don't work from
and mad hops to anyone that can do that
that's amazing but I just found that it
wasn't the lifestyle that I was able to
live because I interacted with my team
and our clients and an almost hourly
basis on video calls all day long this
was my view not the beach this is my
team at Stanford on Halloween no one
tweet this slide they know that I'm
sharing it but they'd probably kill me
if they knew I chose this photo I didn't
know you know if I didn't know any
better this could be any other day but
it was Halloween you'll see my coworker
Carol is dressed as a chicken she's
actually holding a chicken and then
bottom left you'll see is the conference
room of people on campus we had just as
many people working on campus as we did
working remotely and we have everything
from developers designers project
managers writers user experience
researchers both remote and on-site on
this picture we had a lot of fun and
every Monday morning we'd all jump on a
call and the larger team have our
stand-up talk about blockers and really
just kicked off our week so okay I told
the conference organizers there'd be
pictures of cats so you know that's why
they picked my talk but the truth is I
never thought I would be a remote
I was terrified I you know I'm an
extrovert working remotely was really
hard for me I get ideas from being
around other people so even though
Lambert here and I can come up with
great ideas together such as napping on
my keyboard ultimately I still needed to
join remote meetings with my team and I
still needed to collaborate and as the
project manager people were looking to
me to lead those in a collaborative way
just like when I was on campus for the
first six months it's just that now I'll
happen to be floating up on a giant five
foot TV screen on the wall in the
conference room and so while you might
think it's challenging how do you run a
brainstorm meeting without that wait
board and a smell of dry erase marker
right I actually found that it's still
very very doable remotely so today
finally here's the plan
I want to discuss what exactly is a
collaborative remote design working
session other than setting the record
for the most adjectives used in a talk
title and how is this different from
just another regular meeting and then
we'll look at some tools we used and how
I put them to use for running these
working sessions entirely remotely so
it's just a virtual whiteboard sticky
notes and all and then I'll share some
tips and best practices for being
inclusive because all the tools in the
world won't help you if you're not
actually including your team sound good
let's do it so what's the difference
between another regular meeting and a
working session in a traditional meeting
you might be updating each other right
you get in a room you talk about the
work you assign things you update and
then you leave and then you go work on
it so the PM there right
we're telling adding tasks hey front end
team you're gonna go team those
responsive breakpoints now yeah back-end
team go do backend stuff and user
experience designer you're gonna
interview a user or something right and
then we'll all come back together and
talk about what we did wrong because we
weren't actually working together go
team so this isn't just about having
better meetings with your team it's
about changing the way you actually
spend your time together and how you get
that work done so after this you can go
tell your team guess what no more mean
and then come thank me because they're
gonna love it by actually switching to
the term working session even in the
calendar in might I saw a change in the
way people approached the time together
they felt less pressure to bring
finished work to a meeting to share with
the group and we still have daily
stand-ups and sprint reviews for those
of you working on agile teams and are
curious so these are working sessions
outside of that so what exactly is this
collaborative remote design working
session
well it's collaborative because no one
single person is giving a formal
presentation like I'm doing right now
this is not a collaborative talk when
people are co-creating and feeling
included and their ideas are being heard
they're far more engaged and they're not
sitting there on their laptops looking
at pictures of my cats you're working
session should be as hands-on and
interactive as possible and it's remote
so this is a tricky layer right what
does it mean to be remote it doesn't
mean that everyone's working from home
it just means that you're not physically
co-located maybe there's people in a
different office or a different
conference room across campus this
happened at Stanford all the time it
took 20 minutes for me although 30
seconds flat when I sprinted onstage
super late to cross campus to another
meeting so we're saving time by just
calling in remotely and the goal here is
that you're making the content of these
meetings or these working sessions
accessible regardless of anyone's
physical location the day of the working
session the thing about the time you
called in to a meeting on speakerphone
or you were the person on the laptop at
the end of the table with everyone else
in the room you probably couldn't see
the whiteboard with all of their
fabulous ideas you probably couldn't
hear everyone that well and when you did
try to chime in it was awkward and they
asked you to repeat yourself is if you
just interrupted them sound familiar
just didn't feel like you were there in
the room with them so when you set up
these working sessions to work remotely
you're forcing the adoption of tools and
best practices that make this content
actually more accessible and inclusive
for everyone in the room even those
physically there and remote on the
screen and these are design working
sessions because they use a design
thinking process which I'll cover in a
few slides which brings the team along
the journey
designing something together when
there's a shared decision making along
the way you no longer need to fill
people in on conversations or decisions
made without them oh well
the design team mate met last week
during our design review meeting and
made some tweaks to those mock-ups after
I put a note in the JIRA ticket didn't
you see it design is iterative right
things are constantly changing so when
you're making these changes and
decisions together no one gets left
behind and these are working sessions
after all they're not deadline-driven
meetings as I mentioned before people
aren't rushing to get stuff done and it
allows the team to create shared goals
and expectations for how they spend
their time together so we're taking a
page from our accessibility advocates
accessibility is huge in higher
education as it should be everywhere so
when you solve a problem for remote
employee you often solve it for everyone
as a remote project manager I was forced
to keep up with documentation define and
redefine our processes and
over-communicate because someone
couldn't just walk up to my desk anymore
ensure their slack they can ping me but
it's just not the same and when your
remote you want to have access to that
information as quickly and efficiently
as possible
so when you set up these working
sessions to provide all materials to
work remotely such as creating a virtual
whiteboard it creates a much more
cohesive and well documented experience
so raise your hand if you've ever had a
magical brainstorm whiteboard session in
a conference room and you took a picture
of it and guess what I bet that picture
is still sitting on your phone and a
black hole or maybe you posted it on
slack and got a thumbs up emoji
until one day google photos prompts you
hey do you want to archive these 22
pictures of whiteboard photos so with
the virtual whiteboard it can be
revisited modified updated and used
frequently throughout the project
without requiring someone to
painstakingly transcribe all of your
wonderful notes on sticky notes on the
board so this is an example of mural a
tool that we use to recreate these
virtual whiteboards and share link and I
put a link to this whiteboard every
single one of my meeting invites
regardless if we're past the
brainstorming phase or not because we
might come back to it right we might
still want to access this information
later so as I mentioned working sessions
benefit from this design thinking
process since you're bringing everyone
along this journey of designing
something together the source here is
the Stanford d.school they have several
great resources for how to run workshops
with this lots of play books and sort of
worksheets and stuff to walk you through
how to do this but I'm going to cover
the quick basics because this could be
its own talk so just quickly first you
want to empathize with your users you
want to understand how they're feeling
what are their motivations gain an
empathic understanding of the problem
you're trying to solve then you're going
to define the problem or the hypothesis
so typically you create a human centered
problem statement which is really just a
fancy way of saying what are we doing
here for example how can we use
storytelling in a visual and compelling
way so our readers will want to learn
more and feel empowered to keep coming
back to our website instead of we want
our users to click and read our magazine
articles to drive up the number of page
views then you're going to quickly jump
into the idea phase with solutions and
designs this is brainstorm this is where
the magic happens so you can include
ideas for visuals user experience how
you might talk to users even ideas for
infrastructure you think you might need
to solve the problem and then jump into
the prototype experimental phase this is
low fidelity designs wireframes whatever
you need to get a prototype together so
you can get it in front of users as
quickly as possible for immediate
feedback which brings you to testing and
it's okay to fail fast because you're
going to keep going through each of
these different stages as you learn more
about your users means how they're
feeling how they're thinking and
behaving to your designs so you can keep
improving so I want to share an example
feature request of how we might have
taken a feature request into a Design
Thinking working session with our team
remotely so this example the product
owner came to us we worked on websites
at Stanford a product owner came to us
and said as a Content author just
someone that edits content on a website
I want to share the latest article with
a video or a featured image on the home
so that I can drive more traffic to our
magazine articles okay great let's get
in a room let's talk about it team what
do we what do we what's the problem
we're trying to solve who are the users
we're really solving this problem for so
first we empathize and define the
problem the end users the website
visitors or the people we're actually
designing for here so you want to get
everyone in their room thinking about
those users right away not just about
the product owners business needs which
we know are important since they're the
content authors but in our working
session we'll use these frameworks for
example so this again we're using mural
because we're in that brainstorm sort of
emphasized and defined phase on the left
you see this strategize our value
proposition canvas and what that is is
it's looking at your user profile so
understanding their games their pains
what are the tasks the jobs they need to
do when they get to your website right
everyone needs to do something when
they're looking at your website and on
the other side you're looking at your
products your service or your website
and what are those game creators and
those pain relievers and between those
two canvases you'll start to identify a
fit where things are fitting between
your users and what you're providing to
them and where the gaps are what are you
missing what are you not seeing and
that's how you start to define what are
the problems we're really trying to
solve here
so a user experience designer in this
working session with this canvas for
example in mural is getting the whole
team thinking about the end user
experience we have developers in the
room we have obviously the user
experience designer everyone's talking
about this from the beginning and then
on the right is just another example of
the lean UX framework that you can use
to help define the problem so from there
you're gonna get into idea mode and this
can happen in the same working session
sometimes the last phase takes longer it
just depends how big the problem is and
how much you already know or what you
don't know yet so in the idea phase we
use Google draw or envision freehand for
example to quickly sketch in low
fidelity ideas I don't actually have the
mock-ups for this feature request since
I no longer
at Stanford but this is just obviously a
picture of a wireframe but a developers
might start sketching in some ideas for
functionality requirements as our
designers sketching out ideas for how
they want this to lay out on the the new
homepage we're designing maybe our
developer even says oh hey I have this
idea to use this YouTube API and while
they're demoing this all of us in the
room we discover oh we want to use our
own image stills and the ability to
upload those instead of using the
YouTube previews since we know that
custom imagery is really important to
our product owner so we you can see
we're sort of discovering these things
together collaboratively much earlier or
not in the process then we'll jump into
our prototype phase our visual designer
these again admittedly are much higher
fidelity than where they probably
started but this is what I can share
with you so we're looking at mock-ups
there using sketch or envision or Sigma
to collaboratively jump in and work on
these designs and we'll walk through
these technical requirements with our
developers will confirm the user flow
with our user experience designer in the
room as well and finally we'll test and
in our next working session we'll jump
on a call in zoom to share our screens
and watch someone test our prototype for
the very first time you can use tools
like optimal workshop as well to send it
out to like large groups of users to
collect a lot of data but the quickest
way to just test is share someone's
screen and watch them interact with your
prototype for the first time and in this
case I was the guinea pig so I was the
one testing our very first prototype and
on the right there was no play button
our designer immediately was like wait
where's the video play button this
custom icon I created it's missing and
as it turned out Google tag manager was
preventing our custom JavaScript from
loading in the correct order and so you
know if anyone's come across that bug
before that was a fun one to kind of
troubleshoot together but we were able
to really quickly come across some of
these issues early on and get them
resolved because we were sharing our
screens and not just like peeking over
each other's shoulder at the other
person's laptop so so far we've talked
about the format of collaborate
remote working sessions an example
feature built in the design thinking
process remotely so here are some other
tools because I've already mentioned a
few and chances are you're already using
a lot of these but I think but start
thinking about how you can leverage them
to set up a remote working session so
first and foremost nailed down your
video conferencing software it's super
important our team you zoom slack also
has great of you know video capabilities
for ad-hoc calls but we would actually
setup a dedicated zoom number that the
team would just memorize and it kind of
served as our virtual office or just hey
jump on a call and then people would all
meet there so you don't waste time
setting one up when you need to we would
also set up our conference rooms so that
we did have whiteboards in the physical
room directly across from the camera
where the conference room screen was
pointing and then we actually figured
out it's a little creepy but you can
change the settings of the zoom host to
allow far-end camera control so it's a
remote user I could actually control the
camera and like zoom into the whiteboard
and look around which was really
empowering as a remote person I don't
have to interrupt someone in their idea
because I can't see what they're doing
so I was able to kind of feel like I was
in the room with them also other
brainstorming tools mindmeister is a
good one for quick sort of mind mapping
just stream of conscious getting ideas
down Trello is really great another
virtual sticky board like experience
with sorting and voting and commenting
and now it connects to JIRA because that
lasya nones them now so that's cool you
can also use mural and optimal workshop
for user experience testing optimal
workshop has tree jack card sorting
first click analysis and surveys design
mock-ups we were using sketching and
vision for a while but figma sort of
taken over that real time and
collaboration sort of Google Doc
experience for designers which has been
really great so just take advantage of
all of the tools your team is already
using but think about how you can use
them and I'm a remote friendly way and
if there are others that you know of
that I haven't mentioned tweet them at
me always always checking out new tools
and so finally as I mentioned you can
have all the tools in the world but
they're not going to help you if you're
not actually
including your remote team members so I
have a few tips I want to share with you
this first one make remote working an
option for everyone especially for any
managers in the room this might be the
hardest part so maybe find me after if
you find that this is the biggest hurdle
on your team but I call this out to
manager specifically because I think the
culture shift has to start from the top
working from home should not be
considered special treatment or a
privilege and I'm not saying everyone
should work from home every day but they
should have the option and flexibility
to work from when and where they need to
only allowing full-time remote staff to
work remotely creates this really
negative stigma around it and resentment
for those that do so if everyone on the
team has a chance to try it and won't
feel like this dirty little secret that
gets taken advantage of when they
finally get to work from home because
they have a delivery at noon but it also
creates empathy for the on-site team for
the remote team members oh I finally got
to work from home last Thursday I didn't
realize when I hate pretzels right by
the microphone that's all you can hear
number two always turn on the video
camera now of all the tips I'm going to
share I think that this one is the most
important you have to have video and
everyone on the call has to do it
because video helps provide visual cues
like I'm agreeing with you or I'm
confused please keep explaining that
idea it really those facial expressions
are really helpful for staying engaged
and feeling like your ideas are being
heard and headphones are essential for
remote participants I think that goes
without saying but just prevents that
sort of awkward audio gaps in feedback
that you might get so just get a nice
pair of headphones with the mute button
and on the positive side one positive
side effect of remote working I've
learned is that it really flexes your
active listening skills since you are
more aware of when you're interrupting
someone when you have control of your
own mute button sometimes I need to
remember that one when I'm in real life
again with other humans not just my cat
so number three have as much visibility
as if you were in the office do you say
hello to your team when you walk by
their desk in the morning drop a good
morning message and slack to say hi to
your remote teammates too so
people even let us know when they
stepped away from their keyboards for
lunch or when they're signing off for
the day but it's not a hard and fast
rule so there's no real pressure around
it if you forget - we still have daily
stand-ups and that's not just for agile
teams so for those of you that aren't
doing them most of you probably are but
hosts stand-ups with your remote staff
and on-site staff so you can kind of
check out
ok who's working from where today one of
the priorities and really just kick
start the day for your remote teammates
I know as a remote worker that's how I
kind of felt like I was at work even
though I was still in my own house this
is a fun one you can create a team
working agreement that really sets those
baseline expectations and understanding
of how you're gonna do work together
remotely you can create this in a fun
team bonding workshop using and design
thinking process we came up with a fun
team name in ours called team rational
and reasonable we were working on a lot
of legacy code so that just kind of came
up but you can discuss and decide things
like slack is great but when is it
appropriate to use email maybe never we
add conference links to every single
meeting invite regardless if we know a
remote team member is joining or not
because you never know if someone's
plans are gonna change and they're gonna
work from home that day so just having
that video call link already in the
invite it just keeps things moving
smoothly it doesn't feel like someone's
inconveniencing you because they decided
to call in another good one is if there
are more than 20 or 30 replies in slack
thread just hop on a call and hash it
out how do you get a hold of someone if
something is urgent do you need their
cell phone numbers and if you do have a
company-wide policy just make sure that
it's visible and well communicated to
your staff but I also recommend that
give your team that space to create a
working culture that's unique and best
for them to kind of get down into the
nuances of these things so I have a
recap of all of those tips available on
a link at bitly slash remote - tips on
medium which just has all of these tips
in a couple of others but the really big
takeaways from today are remember you're
collaborating you're not presenting in
these working sessions be inclusive of
all your team members both remote and
on-site always use video that one's a
mess
and this is a design thinking process so
just know that in the end you're
bringing all your entire team throughout
that journey of designing something
together thank you and you can find me
on the Internet
[Applause]